-Our next guest can be seen
in the Netflix
stand-up series
"Verified Stand-Up,"
premiering November 28th.
Making her TV debut,
please welcome
the very funny Leslie Liao!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hello!
Yes. Ooh, yes. Hello.
It's so good to be --
It feels so good to be here.
Sorry. I feel like I sound
like I'm always flirting.
Sorry. It's because my voice
is so deep and sensual.
Do you hear that?
Do you like that?
Sorry. Sorry.
I have had this voice
for most of my life.
It's been a problem.
Like, I got this voice
at puberty.
This was me on the playground
trying to make friends.
Okay?
I'd be like, "Hey, Britney,
want to have a sleepover
at my place tonight?"
She's like, "What the..."
"Me, you -- tickle fight?
Let's go. Tickle fight?"
She's like, "Oh, my God."
I grew up in Orange County,
California,
so for most of my life,
I identified as a white person.
It's good to see you all.
But I started to speak
like a white person,
even though I was living
my Asian-American experience.
Like, "I'd go up to all the
skater kids after school like,
"Sup? Anyone want to cruise
over to Kumon,
or, Jansen, you in?
What's more rad
than school after school?
Let's go, dudes."
This is very confusing, okay?
I'm so ashamed.
I can't write my own name
in Mandarin,
but I can draw the Stussy symbol
with my eyes closed.
To this day, I can do it, okay?
I'm doing well, though.
I'm a single woman in my 30s.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm happy. Thank you.
Thank you for the support
for my time in need.
Thank you.
But you know, in my 20s,
I used to be sad
about being single.
It used to bum me out.
You know, it made me very sad.
And now I've grown.
I've matured.
Like, my feelings have evolved.
Like, now I'm angry.
Now mama's pissed.
I don't want to keep
looking for this man.
I want to go home, okay?
When I find him,
I'm going to be like a mom
whose kid got lost
at the grocery store.
Like, "Where have you been?
Get in the car!
That was so embarrassing.
Stop crying.
I'll give you something
to cry about."
You know?
That's love.
I do like a man
that cries, actually.
I'm attracted
to a man who's vulnerable,
someone who's comfortable
sharing his emotions,
the dark parts of his life.
That's sexy. That turns me on.
So, my dirty talk sounds
different these days.
You know, back then,
I wanted you to talk about me.
Now I want to hear about you.
Like, whisper naughty things
in my ear,
like, how many games
did your dad miss?
Ooh! Ooh! The entire season?
How does that make you feel?
Mmm!
Like, look, I'm not going to
open up until you open up.
Do you know what I mean?
Wink, wink.
You got...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's how it works now.
You got it?
But I'm realistic now
in my dating life.
Like, I finally accepted this.
I'm probably not going
to find my "dream man."
And it's fine.
I had way too many things
on the checklist
for this perfect person.
It's not realistic.
You know, you got to let things
go off the checklist.
It's just like house hunting.
You're not going to get all your
must-haves in one place, right?
You got to sacrifice something.
It's either location or size.
Do you know what I mean?
If it's big, I'm going
to drive far for it.
If it's big. Do you get it?
You got to be
realistic now, okay?
You're going to end up
in a place
with a lot of
wear and tear, right?
And you're going to meet
this "house" and be like,
"What did the previous owner
do to this place?
What kind of damage
do I got to live with?
This place is a mess."
Okay?
But it's a struggle for me
being a straight woman.
I really --
I have trouble with it.
I rarely find a man
that gets me smitten right away.
It's hard to explain.
Like, I'm straight,
so I'm attracted to men,
but I don't find men attractive.
Do you know what I mean?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You seem to understand.
Yeah. It's like,
"I want you to hold me,
but do you always
have to wear a hat?"
I'm sorry.
Do you know what I mean?
You're in my eyeline. I'm sorry.
You know?
Look, no offense.
I don't get why I'm straight.
I don't understand it.
Women are gorgeous.
Like, any woman -- beautiful.
Look -- beautiful.
Any woman could walk by
and take your breath away.
But I have never seen
some floating hat in a crowd
and time stopped.
I've never, never been like,
"Oh, my, my, my!"
Like never -- Like,
"Who is that man in those
Costco basketball shorts?
Yummy!"
Okay, I've said enough.
I'm Leslie Liao.
Sorry. Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Fantastic! Leslie Liao!
"Verified Stand-Up" is streaming
November 28th on Netflix.
Leslie Liao! We'll be
right back, everybody.